to
this district planning committee meeting
this evening wednesday the 5th of august
my name is councillor mark hurd chairman
of the malden district planning
committee
the setup of this meeting has been
designed to mitigate the covid
and we have asked members to work to the
protocols agreed at the council meeting
on the 29th of april
2021 in the interests of member and
officer safety now i understand
this meeting is to be live streamed
we may be having some technical
difficulties but it will be available
tomorrow so i do welcome any viewers
present
uh it will be recorded and by being
present at the meeting
you are giving consent to also being
recorded
members and officers during each item
please raise your hand
or hold up the white card on the desk in
front of you to
indicate if you wish to speak and i will
then invite you at the appropriate time
i encourage all members to keep
contributions clear and concise and
when invited to speak please remain
seated
when speaking and referring to the
agenda papers please ensure you
reference a page
or paragraph number i've also been asked
to remind you
that we have a roving mic
which will come to you please do not
speak until the
mic arrives thank you very much
i'll move on now to agenda item 2
apologies for absence please tara
[Music]
thank you very much agenda item 3
is minutes of the last meeting this is
found on pages
7 to 16 and it's recommended that the
minutes of the meeting of the district
planning committee
which was held on the 9th of june 2021
found on pages 7-13 are approved as a
true
and accurate record they're presented
for accuracy only iso move do i have a
seconder
councilor mays thank you very much
members can we agree
these by send please
thank you very much
we have we have other apologies
councillor bell as well thank you very
much that's recorded
agenda item four is declarations of
interest this is to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests
other pecuniary interests or
non-pecuniary interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard
to paragraphs six to eight inclusive of
the code of conduct for members
and members are reminded that they are
required to disclose any such interests
as soon as they become aware
should the need arise throughout the
meeting do i have
any declarations
uh yes thank you chairman uh just i'm a
member of essex county council who are
consultants
on uh planning applications thank you
very much
councillor fleming
okay i'm not sure if we picked that up
that's non-pecuniary as
a member of essex county council
and non-pecuniary for councillor stamp
any other
declarations please
no thank you very much i move on then to
agenda item
5 which is 21.00479
ful this is location being the
land north of marsh road burnamon crouch
this is found on pages 15 to 50
and also on the members update pages
3 to eight um i think the officer is
miss matthews so could i ask you please
miss matthews to present the report
thank you
thank you chairman good evening members
so this is an application
on land at marsh road in burma crouch
and before i start the
chairman has already made reference to
the update which had been previously
circulated but i do have some further
verbal updates um
one is that i have heard back now from
s county council team and they still
require some additional information
and but there is a condition recommended
which would cover
cover that issue and essex county
council highways have raised no
objection
and they have asked for conditions to be
imposed
and they're saying that the financial
contribution required as part of the
previous application
is still necessary so there would need
to be
an amendment to the recommendation
to make sure that all those conditions
and financial contribution is
secured if if it's still necessary
i also heard that from the waste team
and they've made some
comments and recommendations in terms of
waste storage and collection
and the application has does have a
refuse strategy submitted with it
um i haven't it was received very late
in the days i haven't had a chance to
look through
all the details but um from what i've
seen um
it's either already covered in the
information submitted or it could easily
be
dealt with by condition if the
application was approved
so this is an application for um
residential residential development
comprising
58 residential dwellings and public open
space landscaping associated
infrastructure
and this is it is a revised application
to one that was approved at the end of
last year
and the result would be that there will
be 15 additional dwellings on the
um site as a whole and they'll be
with associated revision to the dwelling
mix and alterations to the layout
so this site is one of the allocated
sites in burnham
known as s2k which is located north of
marsh road east of saint mary's church
and west of the railway line
and the site is allocated for a minimum
of 90 dwellings within the local
development plan
and as i said before planned permission
has already been grounded for 90
dwellings on this site
there's mainly residential development
to the south there's also a school
public footpath on the western boundary
beyond which there are residential
properties
renting marsh road there's also a
residential property
sandwiched between part of the southern
boundary the site and and marsh road
and the applicant has provided this
overlay to try and illustrate the
changes
to the approved scheme so the revised
the current proposal is in
green and it's been overlaid
with the red which is the previous
application
permission so i've got a slightly larger
version of the
side of the site that is affected
by this in particular this application
so the the main changes are
um that's worth pointing out is this
green block here which is
an extra block of flats in this corner
the um
these dwellings have been pushed over to
the
west um to make space for additional
properties
and and these properties here have been
moved over slightly
there are rather smaller changes but
they're the the main ones may be to
denote
and this is a layout and it shows where
the affordable housing units would be
and they're the ones with the
red asterisks
and this is just a colored layout it's
the same the same layout but just
um in color and perhaps a bit clearer to
show where the um
how the properties would be laid out so
just to clarify we've got the red line
there around the edge
um which is the original application
site and then we've got the
four areas um shaded
and outlined in blue and they're the
elements of the previous
permission that will remain unchanged
and some street scenes that illustrate
um
what the site will look like they've got
a a across the top which is
um and this is the key here showing
where that a a
street scene would be and then bb um
down this side here
and at the end of this bb
there is the extra block of flats
referred to
and we've also got street scenes of um c
and c and also d to d
and some examples of the market housing
proposed
and they're very similar to the
properties that have already been
approved
so again only standard
um house types
and then we've got some of the
affordable housing for these are the
flatted blocks so that's one of the
blocks
and then you've got a second block both
blocks would have
six um flats in each
and this is an example of the affordable
housing
um which will be houses and plants
and these are some just some um photos
that
things have probably moved on slightly
because they were taken a few weeks ago
but it just illustrates that the site is
a building site and
construction of the approved scheme has
already commenced
so in conclusion the proposed
development is located with one of
within one of the strategically
allocated sites in burnham and complies
with the designated requirement that the
site is developed for a minimum of 90
dwellings
but the more sufficient provision for
infrastructure services and facilities
will be made as part of the development
to meet the requirements of the relevant
local development plan policies and
therefore
of us to feel that the principle of the
development is acceptable
the development is considered to provide
suitable provision of affordable housing
and housing mix and
the development would neither be harmful
to the character appearance of the area
or the site
in order to be harmful to the immunities
the neighboring occupiers or certainly
no more so than the
originally approved scheme it would also
make adequate provision for off-site
off-street parking and would not have an
adverse impact on nature conservation
the tilted balance is engaged and
currently due to the lack of
a five-year housing land supply and the
development is considered to be
sustainable
and i set out in the mppf as the
development would not cause any material
harm the main benefits of the proposal
are considered to be the social benefits
associated with the contribution the
development would make
to the council's housing land supply
and at a time when the supply is
significant significantly below the
five-year minimum required
there would also be some economic
benefits therefore subject to conditions
recommended and in addition to those
referred to in the updates and the
section 106 agreement the development
would be acceptable and
in accordance with the development plan
for the area and he's recommended for
approval on that basis thank you
[Applause]
thank you miss matthews now we have one
public participant
for this planning application in line
with the public
participation scheme i will now invite
the agent mr milne from saviles to read
out
his submission i remind you that you are
allocated two minutes only for public
speaking
in accordance with the scheme thank you
mr milne
members thank you for giving me the
opportunity to speak in support of the
application
my name is oliver milne from saviles who
are taylor win piece planning consultant
on this project
firstly we'd like to thank officers for
their report and their positive
recommendation which we fully support
as you have heard taylor wimpey has
identified an opportunity to increase
the number of one and two bedroom homes
at the site
which directly responds to unidentified
local need and demand
as a result of this the total number of
new homes to be delivered across the
site will increase by 15
with a corresponding uplift in
affordable housing it is in this context
i would like to cover a few points at
the heart of both national and local
planning policy and guidance
it's a presumption in favor of
sustainable development coupled with
this
is a directive for the effective use of
land in meeting the need for new homes
the site is a sustainable accessible and
allocated site
which in the context of the council
being unable to demonstrate five-year
housing land supply
has the potential to further contribute
to the district supply
in terms of the quality of the new homes
all have been designed to accorded
relevant policy standards and
requirements
with no signs of over development all of
the homes are ndss compliant
a dual aspect and a policy compliant
levels of private community space
car parking and cycle parking all of the
new homes will be of a high quality for
future residents
in terms of any extra demand and impact
created by additional residents
the development already includes public
open space well in excess of the policy
requirement
whilst an uplift in the relevant
financial contributions will be secured
as part of the legal agreement
the proposals have been thoroughly
tested and we are pleased that officers
of the council have endorsed our
assessments
leading to a positive and well-balanced
officer report with a recommendation for
approval
with officers concluding that the
development would not cause any material
harm
given all of this we respectfully
request that the application be approved
in accordance with your officer's
recommendation
thank you for listening
thank you very much mr mill
members i'm now going to open the debate
and i'm going to
invite you to put any questions or make
any comments
that you have on the report so i have a
number of hands
first hand dot if you just hold on to
them i've got counsellor
uh counsellor nunn edwards
uh councillor skeens councillor
um
yes thank you very much chair um and
thank you miss matthews um
and um uh also mr milne for
your presentations um there are a number
of things that are confusing me about
this application
first of all the number are we really
talking about an additional
15 on the previous approved number
or are we talking about 58 or are we
talking about
73 so is this application simply to add
another 15 uh units
that's the first question the second
thing is i'm a bit troubled that we've
um on top of the member update that
we've got already
there there's some additional
information which hasn't been properly
analyzed yet by the sounds of it
that can be addressed through conditions
well if we don't know what the
what the detail is how can we look at
the conditions
and there are also some um
uh consultees that require additional
information from us by the sounds of it
so those things are troubling me a bit
and i think
i value some clarification i'd also
like to go back to the site plan to just
be totally clear
how close these additional buildings
will be
to the church thank you
thank you councilman it's celine i know
miss matthews
um thank you chairman in terms of the
numbers
um the whole site um
that's the big site there outlined in
red that
that has find permission for 90
dwellings
this area here has permission for
getting right 43 dwellings they now want
plan permission for
58 dwellings so that's an additional 15
and that will take the total for the
whole site up to 105.
does that answer your question about
numbers
yes it's a lot clearer okay
fine so it needs an additional 15 units
on a previously approved 43.
yes that's right thank you that's that's
clear
thank you thank you very much
thank you and yeah so um yeah apologies
for the
um the lateness of some of the updates
but i have literally
only just received emails from highways
and
and said despite having asked them and
they promised that they'd be with me by
yesterday
um but officers are confident that the
issues that they've raised
are new issues or issues that can't
haven't been already covered and
addressed in in the report and that's
before you um do need additional
information but
it's it's technical information and this
is the site that's already got planned
commission has already got
um approval for the drainage so we're
only looking at the
an extra 15 properties on there so
um that i'm sure the developer will be
able to address it and there is a
condition recommended
to make sure that extra information
comes in and is approved
thank you councilman councillor edwards
next door
uh thank you
page 39 7.3
where it says the applicant is meeting
the 40
affordable requirement however
the affordable housing mix as proposed
does not comply with the results
of the 2021 local housing needs
assessment
so i'm a bit confused with what it says
on one it doesn't apply and the other it
does
thank you thank you mr matthews yes
through
your chairman the um the situation is
the application came in in april
um at which time the the local
news housing assessment was not produced
and that's only
been published very recently in the last
three weeks or so and so the application
was
was um submitted on the basis of the the
uh
2014 which was what we were using before
and so from the housing manager's point
of view
he felt that he needed to to state
that he doesn't comply with the local
housing needs assessment
and but the um because this is an
application to
change what has already been approved
and the local housing
needs assessment came out very recently
and
as officers we felt that it would be
unreasonable now to impose the local
news housing assessment on
on this particular scheme but certainly
moving forward any applications received
um since the the housing news assessment
has been published will certainly be
expected to
fully comply with the um the housing mix
there
and the other point i was going to make
is that the only difference
between what they're proposing and what
the local housing news assessment would
ideally ask for would be
one four bedroom house instead of one of
the smaller units so
the difference is fairly small in in any
event even if
them um
even taking into account the more recent
housing needs assessment
can i come back thank you for that
response
the only reason i picked up it was
because it did say that it doesn't
comply and i just picked on that bit
thank you very much thank you um
i see i see you indicating um council
harlow i've got your name
down thank you uh councillor skeens is
next
yes uh i i have concerns about things
that don't comply
uh if it doesn't comply it doesn't
comply there's no reason why
it can't be submitted again if it
doesn't comply
could you also claim so i'm getting
confused still confused about the
figures
the total for the plot is how many 90
what
that have been approved
so and we're having another 15 on top of
that
okay my concern uh which are
is is that burnham is already massively
is is overloaded
there's a big public concern about it
being overloaded
that we don't have the infrastructure
and indeed there's a part in the uh
in the local development plan which
talks about that if we exceed numbers
put out in our local plan
then we need to ensure that
infrastructure is put in place first
i'm very concerned about more houses
uh um going on to this site and also
what i cannot understand and why
and i would love an explanation from
somebody
is how it can be that we go through the
process of of of
approving a certain number of houses
either and then suddenly oh they found
room for more as if they could couldn't
have known that before
i find that very difficult to deal with
i mean
and it makes frankly it makes the public
feel cynical about it they feel
look you know the developers have said
this and now they're adding this on and
that does not i don't think that's good
reputationally
so i do have concerns i'm obviously
listening to the bait
debate but i am worried about this up
this increase in the number of houses
thank you okay thank you councillor
schemes
uh counselor channel
she's there at the back yeah at the back
shane thank you
that's it
um thank you chairman yes
i'm a little bit confused in the figures
regarding the parking
maybe i've read it wrong but it seems to
me there's some extra spaces coming
could that be visitor parking have i
read the report incorrectly
and also i've read that the orchard's
going to be reduced really what i want
to know is obviously if you're putting
15 houses on something's going to be
taken away
it looked to me like it was the orchards
going to have a deficit of over 500
square meters
um and there's something else referred
to in terms of public open space
and i understand there'll be another
block of flats so i suppose that might
form part of the element
the other area which is concerning me is
the 106 agreement
in which it appears to me there's been
one i'm assuming
agreed when the 90 were approved in
terms of heads of terms
and now i'm reading about there could be
some jiggery pokey that's my wording not
necessarily yours
which may alter the figures of that
heads of term am i corrupt
am i correct or am i wrong and i'm just
interested to know why perhaps that sort
of information could not be
at this committee tonight so we're very
very clear
what the heads of terms should actually
be should this be approved
thank you thank you miss matthews
i've got three questions parking what's
been taken away in the heads of term
the in terms of the parking i think um
i think i would just say that all the
properties proposed
have sufficient parking um to comply
with the adopted standards so that's
um two spaces for two and three beds and
three spaces for four
beds plus and um and one space for
one beds um and plus the visitors facing
parking spaces which is one per four
parking spaces
so um the the numbers are set out in in
the report but
but if the scheme is fully compliant
with the current adopted
vendors in terms of the number of spaces
and also their
size um and in terms of
the the loss of public open space
obviously they didn't
you know there hasn't need to be made
some space for the actual unit so
um correcting saying that um an area of
orchard down here in the south
eastern corner would be um eaten into
slightly by
the block of flats and there was also
going to be a slightly bigger
area of um open space i don't know
whether it would be
public or private but in terms of the
landscaping there will be a
loss in that area there but my my point
is that they're the main
main two changes but in terms of public
open space there's a very very
extensive area all across the top of the
site and also there's the
um play area along the western boundary
and and most of the auction would be
would be retained
as well in terms of the section 106 um
the the uncertainty is associated with
the fact that this is
um forms part of a site that's already
got planning permission
um and it's extra units on top of what's
been approved so
the only only uncertainty is to make
sure that developer isn't paying twice
um so that any any contributions that
were
triggered as part of the existing 106 on
the 90 units
they don't have to pay again for the
same units that are being replaced
basically by by this scheme so that's
if i think that's what you were
getting at or asking about my
understanding is correct
chairman yes may i come back with yes
yes um yes you're correct
uh miss matthews but to me if you're
getting 15 additional houses
or properties whatever form they are to
me
you're saying the developer shouldn't
pay twice but we've just heard tonight
these are additional to the 90 already
agreed we're going up to 105.
so therefore to me surely there should
be more monies accruing under the 106.
not where would the developer be paying
for are you talking on the access road
or something
or elements of that but surely if we're
talking about additional
15 dwellings that must actually have an
increase somewhere within the 106
agreements that should be formulated and
agreed under the 106
agreement maybe i'm wrong i don't know
because i'm not an expert on this
there certainly would be additional
contributions required both for
education
and nhs um and i can't remember if
there's an another one off
my head but all the financial
contributions that were
required by the original scheme and with
the 15 extra units
and certainly for the education and the
nhs there will be an additional payment
to make and i think one of the issues is
the consultation responses are based on
the
fifth on 58 houses proposed
and not the extra 15 and
so i think there has been perhaps some
double counting um
going on and they've been treated as
separate applications when in fact there
it's an amendment to something that's
already existing so
but in answer to question yes there
would be extra financial contributions
but they will
for this application um
they would need it need to be linked in
in some way and i'm going to leave it to
the legal
solicitors to work out how to do it and
so
that if taylor wimpy um
paid for the financial contributions of
the 90 units
they wouldn't have to pay again um for
the whole of this scheme they'd only
have to pay for the extra 50.
have i explained it well enough yes i
think so i'd
quite like to know the figures tonight i
guess that's where i'm coming from
really
i think i think the the extra 15 is for
a second block
am i right and the
extra 15 consists partly of an edge
above the flats for that which would be
sixth
but there would also be extra units um
in the
uh number of houses as well right
yeah that's my understanding okay all
right thank you very much
councillor cancer lagging next
uh thanks chad um i too
also had a a bit of a difficult time
understanding the figures that are
actually presented in the report because
i won't go over what the other members
have said but we started off talking
about
15 dwellings with an additional 58
additional 15
and then we got confused with the car
parking in sections
3.13 was talking about 203 spaces per
unit so i got myself in the right tis
was
um straight from the get-go but you've
confirmed that the
the actual the amendments are going to
be eaten into the orchard
is that correct
and that's that's the main area where
they've made
extra space okay thank you for that i
think in terms of the
um the scheme as a whole yeah all i'm
interested in is what it actually eats
into or what was promised to be
delivered on the initial application mr
matthews thank you
another concern in the in the report was
section 3.1.17
it talks about the supporting documents
that were being resubmitted
obviously there are many in their nature
but they talk about being resubmitted
but they don't talk about the documents
that were resubmitted the amendments
that actually spoke to this proposed
change
also we talked about on page 19 section
3.2.1
and we've covered it already about that
the minimum delivery for 90 dwellings in
number
well if the lpa decides that they only
want 90 then
90 should be why should we accept
another 15.
if we don't have another set 15 we don't
need additional funding we don't have
additional burden
on the services that are already
stretched at the time
another concern i have is about section
4 4.1
it talks in the report about members
attention is drawn to a list of
background papers
attached to this agenda there were no
background papers attached to the agenda
so i'm trying to be a better member
in the decision making process and it
talked to 43 attachments
so i feel i'm not fully um hopefully to
be able to
to make a determination without the
levels of detail
um in the subsections 5.2.3 it talks of
maintaining green spaces and the loss of
an orchard no matter how small
and the loss of green space is again
with the the greening of the
the district to do with the essex
strategy and on our own commitments
and the risk of flooding because it's in
a level two three flood zone i believe
when it's just been declared that the
world's flooding worse than it ever has
that also concerns me yes we may be able
to mitigate it but i just want to raise
that concern
and it talks about nature conservation
in 5.6
516.1 on page 32.
talks about open spaces should be
protected again the orchard area is
quite a lovely open space and i felt
that should be protected
and i think councilor edwards mentioned
that there's also
areas that have been noted within the
report where we haven't had
feedback and i think again
maybe being time pressed on situations
like this um
for maybe a kpi i don't know we should
really have all the information in in
place uh
and my last my last concern really
doesn't need opening is
when it refers dramatically in the
report about the national planning
policy framework section seven
you know it does talk about
environmental objectives you know
mitigating
and adapting to climate change and low
carbon
the more you build the more challenge
you're going to have to actually fulfill
that requirement so they're just
concerns that i have but you've answered
my main question ms matthews which is it
does it into the orchard of which i'm
grateful for
thank you have a good chair thank you
councillor lagan
uh i'm going out to uh councillor sue
white
just at the back saying there keep going
around
gentleman here that's the castle
musical chairs thanks james um thank you
for watching um on page 37
essex county council has a holding
objection to the essex um
surface water flooding uh i've got
complex
problems in 3.1.2 um part of the site is
in flood zones two and three and we
should not be building anywhere on two
oh sorry three and two is doubtful um
and any small application has to have a
flood report done
and finished before putting the
application in and they say that
additional housing
will cause an additional strain so why
are we allowing the big developers to
come in with these applications with
incomplete information i'm sorry i just
don't accept that as being
acceptable you know that that should
have been done prior
um the other thing is with the um
oh 5.1.6 and also on page 37. natural
england
um require a habitat regulation
assessment
well that's fine but i can't see
anywhere in the paperwork but there's a
net gain because there should be a net
gain it shouldn't just be about
about finances and i can't see any net
gain and the thing is
the previous application would have had
presumably i would hope the officers had
a net benefit of a certain percentage
this is all required under the new um
legislation for habitat
assessments that natural england have
published in the last two months
and that i cannot see so what is the
percentage of habitat
improvement in line with natural
england's current guidance
what was the previous assessment with
the percentage
and how much has it reduced and and
doing 127 pounds for the rams agreement
does not cover
the habitat orchards have a very high
habitat value
so where are you getting the habitat
replacement from
because i can't see it natural england
require it so unless i missed it
could the officers confirm um and the
other thing is
and with the previous and in other parts
of this application we were promised a
bridal way i do ride horses but not in
burnham so it's a slight
um interest there where is our bridle
where i can see nothing i can't see
footpaths i can't see anything at all
and that's in our ldp and it's in our
planning policies that we're going to
create by the ways
um and as i say the orchard we could
theoretically have had a broader path in
but it's been removed and i'm really
concerned
that it doesn't appear unless i'm
mistaken that we do not have the
increase in habitat that natural england
now require so so where is it and how
much is it thank you very much
thank you councillor white miss matthews
quite a few questions there i've noted
most of those
have you uh you know to answer them
please
yes on them i'll try as i can
um in terms of flood risks two and three
the only parts of the site which are at
risk of flooding
are these areas at the top where no
houses are are being proposed
and no building has been approached and
and that flood risk associated with the
brook that runs along the northern
boundary
and so in terms of any of the new
occupiers being at risk of flooding then
and that isn't
isn't an issue and the
application was supported by a flood
risk assessment
the um which um
was is the same one as the um the first
application
but um in terms of saids they're looking
at
um perhaps more and technical issues
and um in particular surface water
drainage
and they want to they will their aim is
to ensure that
the surface water runoff from the site
is
is no greater than it is um
currently and it was obviously a
greenfield site so you know the runoff
rates will be
um at greenfield levels and but
there's whilst there's they're saying
that um they need some more information
um it's if they're not saying that
this this development can't be can't be
done satisfactorily they're just saying
they need
the developer needs to demonstrate how
how they're going to do it so if the
if the runoff is too great then there'd
have to be
some um on-site storage of the runoff so
that it could then be
um release more slowly
um and maintain that greenfield rate so
and there's lots of technical ways of
doing that some are more expensive than
others but
that that's the requirement and there
will be a way of doing it
and it's just a matter of the developer
coming up with the solution that that
says they're happy with
and the conditions recommended will
ensure that that process that that
discussion that has been ongoing will
continue until a solution is found and
if a solution can't be found then
the condition won't be discharged and
venom won't be able to lawfully go ahead
um but um so this is that does that
control if you like and um hopefully
that gives members some peace of mind
that um that issue
will be will be sorted out and um
there's
no reason to be concerned that sids
haven't been able to
withdraw their objection um as of as of
today um
so in terms of why we're accepting
applications with insufficient
information
there are there is the the list of
documents that an application needs to
come in
with the validation check validation
list
and this application all the documents
required by that list was
submitted um
very often it can be that the documents
that come in
aren't sufficient and then there aren't
enough details in them
and but in terms of being able to turn
an application away on the basis
um of the documents not being there that
this wasn't possible in this case
because all the documents required were
were there and the fredericks assessment
has previously been
accepted and as being satisfactory
um in terms of the
hra and under the habitats regulations
that is um there is a small section in
the report which talks about stage one
and stage two that process
so that has been gone through and
offices are satisfied that the
application and the proposal
would be acceptable from the hra
process and in terms of net gain
essence county council ecology have been
assorted on the application
and they recommend a condition is
imposed to require ecological mitigation
measures and also ecological
enhancements
as set out in the ecological impact
assessment which came in with the
application
and i don't know percentage that would
be
but there is provision there for
enhancements and
our expert advisors on those issues have
advised that
the um application is satisfactory and
that can
the imposition in that condition would
would address any um
would satisfy that requirement for net
gain and
there is no bridle way through this site
um
but in terms of footpaths and footpath
links with the um
the surrounding areas and also within
the site they are
exactly the same as what was approved as
part of their previous application
as i mentioned earlier there's a public
footpath which runs
along the western bound of the site that
would be retained and
that remains the same as previously
approved um
so in that respect um no concerns were
raised
in terms of the provision for um public
footpaths or public rights way or
pedestrian access within the site and
and
connections with its surroundings sorry
going a bit quirky thank you
thank you councillor hull next
thank you and having a living there
um it's already really hard to get to
the doctors
um the schools are all um overflow
you can't get a place at the schools the
roads aren't able to cope
um and as for the bridal ways we were
promised to by the way you've got one of
the largest riding schools in the area
we've got no bridleways in burnham it
was definitely promised
uh when we put the application in once
again a great
you have builders coming along
and changing their mind um at the last
minute
it's not fair on people that live there
all the time this happens
we just don't get what we promised in
the beginning
right thank you i don't think there was
a question in there
more of a more of a statement thank you
councillor swain
uh just second person second one along
here
shane that's it
thank you thank you chairman yes
um this is a significant increase in
um numbers of housing for this
particular
area and it seems to be basically at the
expense of
orchard and green space and community
areas
um perhaps also an expense of some
amenity
for individual properties
and in that connection um i noted in
3114 there was
there was mention about the size of
gardens for
the private two bed houses no mention
of whether the affordable ones get a
similar size of garden which i would
certainly hope
but on the
question of sads and so on
i i assume that
um there will be accepted agreement
um from essex otherwise presumably the
the application would fail but my
concern with things like
suds and loose blue the blue spaces the
green spaces and
and um probably quite a lot of the the
roadways
with if they're not adopted is how they
will be
managed and um how um
[Music]
the performance of um
can be gauged and kept up to scratch in
maintaining the subs
and the green spaces
thank you thank you
so uh miss matthews could we just
confirm it says all the all the pro
in 314 all the private garden areas
would measure at least 50 square meters
for the two bedroomed houses do we
uh all we've got is the uh communal area
the amenity space
so do we have the amenity area for the
new block um
yes chairman the um yes so that both the
blocks
would be provided with sufficient
communal area to comply with the
design guide and that private reference
in the port
in the fort is to private gardens and
not
the private houses so um that means that
both the private and the affordable
houses all have
private amenity spaces or might say i'll
say different the affordable housing and
the market housing
all have um private immunity space which
complies with the design guide minimums
and so i think that answers um council
swain's question about that
in terms of management the the public
open space and
they said that would be through
a management company in a very similar
way to um
most new developments that come forward
and that's all
um managed and controlled through the
section 106 agreement and so one would
have been required as part of the
existing permission for the 90 dwellings
and that would be
followed through with any 1 or 6
agreement associated with
with this revised scheme thank you
right so there will be a sad agreement
thank you
um yes councillor stilts
thank you mr chairman i've read through
this document
um seeing as this council has now
declared
a climate emergency statement
i'm just looking through this and can
you tell me how many of these new
dwellings will have
solar panels how many will have electric
charging points for the cars and how
many will have recyclable water
grey water tanks
and also heat exchange
conversion pumps
thank you very much solar panels
electric charging points
uh uh heat exchangers
and uh water er
yeah great water thank you
there has been no reference to
those measures or
features that you um refer to
um as part of the application and the
the main issue um as far as concerned at
the moment is that
the um there's no policy within the
current adopted local
development plan to require these
measures to be
introduced i'm sure that is something
that will be worked on
and included in the revised local plan
which is
in the process of being um
that process has started but um
it's certainly not a requirement that we
could
we can ask for but we can't um require
and it's not something that um the
application
could be refused for um on because of
the lack of the policy support so that
would make
such a refusal um
you know liable to um not being
successful at appeal
thank you right uh members i know that
uh councillor stamp wishes to speak but
uh yes councillor fleming
right on the corner shane thank you well
done
thank you chair i just wanted to come
back to miss matthew's last point
i was just looking at conditions
condition 18
it says furthermore fast charging point
shall be provided adjacent to at least
one
parking space for each new dwelling
yes sorry that um in terms of vehicle
parking
and that is within our current vehicle
parking standards so yes that is
that is something we can ask for i was
um i was talking about more the solar
panels and the
recycling water and perhaps some of the
other um
energy efficient and green elements that
that could have could have been enclosed
so sorry yes the electric charging point
would be required
um in line with the current um vehicle
adopted parking standards
mr lee you want to speak thank you
chairman just uh
a couple of members have brought this up
sort of thing for a point of clarity
um the council has a you know announced
that
climate emergency and obviously that's
consideration for the council but it
isn't a consideration of any significant
determination of plan applications which
always start with the
local plan with our adopted planning
policies and
um you know and we have to look at what
is acknowledged and what is not in
acknowledged material consideration
the mppf is very clear that climate
change and the emergency and you know
various positions we have across the uh
different you know conferences etc
is very important in the plan making
process but it is silent on the decision
making process
and that is our guide for decision
makers on how we should be assessing
applications so
while you know we are keen to
improve climate change and you know
ecology et cetera and all these other
various matters we only can tie in and
what we can't tie into is what our
policies say and what material
considerations say
and that that that is the issue is and i
think some of
you said you maybe something that you
know as an authority we need to look at
more robustly through the uh
the view of the ldp but our policies you
know
are what they are at the moment as ms
matthew said in relation to charging
points we can embrace that because
that's been our car parking standards
but in relation to lots of the other
things
they aren't in our adopted policies so
we unfortunately can't impose them
or it can't form a reasonable condition
or anything like that thank you chairman
thank you um councillor skins you've
indicated that you just made a quick
point then if you will
um clearly we have another climate
emergency so
uh it strikes me that all new builds uh
need to have all these provisions put in
so i'm re i'm calling for this council
to at the net
to that we make an agenda point and make
the decision
at council rather than waiting for the
development of the new ldp actually make
a
policy decision that all new builds have
to have
all the uh the list of requirements as
uh
suggested by council stilts because
otherwise
we're not treating it like an emergency
thank you mr lee did you want to come
back on that
hm obviously you know that would be a
decision for council obviously i'd just
advise members that
any planning policy needs to go through
a very strict
uh process which includes
evidence-basing
going through uh consultation and
examination in public so
that wouldn't be a decision that we
could give any weight to in the
determination of a planning application
would be my advice thank you chairman
all right thank you i'm going to move to
um sorry is that kitten
sorry counselor seancey sorry i couldn't
quite see the
council seanc uh thank you chairman
um just very briefly um i fully
understand
what mr lee was saying um
but i also agree with councillor skeins
and i don't think it's necessarily
incumbent upon developers
to actually um kind of bring themselves
down to the level of the council
to comply you know they can do these
things off their own back surely
um and will be um much more highly
thought of
because of it um you know these things
need to be
raised and not um taken down to the base
level
thank you chairman thank you councillor
seancy
um okay so going back to this
application i'd like to turn now to
councillor stamp okay thank you chairman
and i'm actually disappointed with the
developer
um i thought part of the um sale of the
land
uh specifically i remember when the sale
was going through
the stipulation was the orchard we've
had nothing but trouble
regarding the orchard because originally
it was put at the side
to provide a buffer from the existing
houses
that then wasn't allowed i think due to
pipe work and i know mr lee most
probably doesn't know about this but
there was a great ferrari about it
had long conversations with the
applicant and the developer
and because they said it couldn't it
couldn't go there because of pipe work
so it was moved at the top
i personally didn't want it moving at
the top but there's nothing we could do
about it the council had agreed it
and it actually went and moved to the
top and now what absolutely stands me is
that they know how
passionate we are we're rural it's all
semi-rural
and you want to get rid of um 540 square
meters to put another block of flats
there
you are supposed to be sort of working
within the community and the
council as far as i'm concerned and i
actually feel quite fronted that you
want to put another
15 houses on a site when you know
whether whether it's county council
agree that we haven't got any
school places we know for a fact this
development is opposite saint mary's
there are no places that saint mary's
almost under are no places are agreeing
next year to put
two-form entry in at the moment we've
got houses and residents in burnham
who cannot walk to their local schools
we're supposed to be doing a climate
exactly what everybody said a climate
emergency strategy
but yet we're putting our children on
buses to go out
to incorporate more houses being
developed within the district
burnham crouch has been hammered we have
been front-loaded by the houses
and i think it's a real shame that
taylor wimpy who have an excellent
excellent record for dealing and
providing
good houses and now reducing the size of
gardens to cram 15
extra houses in i and i i do apologize
officers and and developer it says
significant infrastructure constraints
exist which will strictly limit the
capacity of growth in malden haybridge
and burnham
crouch in excess of that set out in
policy s2
okay we know we've got access we know
that our infrastructure
is creaking if not um breaking at the
seams
and i also want to respond to um
councillor white
when she said about and and and
councillor hull
policy s6 starts quite clearly like
quite clearly sorry um safe pedestrian
cycling and bridal way links are
provided from the development to the
town centre and where applicable to
other public services
facilities and an existing urban area we
don't
obviously meet that of this application
either and i think it's a valid point in
birmingham crotch we've got excellent
ride in school uh we commemorate and the
the horse riders go down and i really
don't want horses and people who
exercise the health and well-being
excluded from new development and as far
as i'm concerned concerned and
can see nearly every new development so
far and not being horse friendly i don't
ride a horse i'd fall off it even though
and hold cats around has offered to put
me on one i haven't taken you up on that
and i also would like to ask a question
instead of my normal speech before mr
lee tells me off because i always say
about the lack of infrastructure schools
etc
can you tell me where we have the same
size height bridge of 9.7 meters
on the in this area um where these flats
where the height of these flats are
because i i can't remember any if there
is one
um do you want me to stop there because
i've got a few it gives gives me a
chance to catch my breath
well uh you're uh you're you're taking
your
your time uh on your your your allotted
time
counseling
are you able to come back on any of
those miss matthews at the moment
through chairman um in terms of
local schools and other infrastructure
if this application is approved there
will be an expectation
that a financial contribution as
required by the
county council schools education will be
required and secured through the 106
agreement so whilst there might not be
capacity now there is provision for that
capacity to be
increased for the future and to take
into account the extra
children who would be living in in
burnham
um policy s2 does does say about
um significant infrastructure
constraints
including in in burnham but my
understanding is that
sentence was uh is in the policy and
it was put in the policy at a time when
there was going to be significantly more
more housing development proposed for
burnham than
than is currently the case in the
current local plan
um current county council highways have
raised no objection to the proposal
and and also also you know realizing the
point that this is for
a relatively small number of extra
properties on the site
um which has already got planned
permission for for 90 so in terms of
extra strain on it
on the infrastructure that would be
fairly minimal
um in the context of the development as
a whole
and the policy s6 talks about
um requirements for bridal ways um
they're there there isn't a bribe away
um requirement as possible as part of
this
uh development but um
this as i know this application is to
amend and
increase the number of dwellings on a on
the site um
and therefore it would be unreasonable
to make that requirement
of the current application because that
is just for 15 houses
um so um and i
i don't know enough about the original
application not being case officer to
know
whether that issue was ever raised and
what came
came of it but certainly in respect to
the current application
um that wouldn't be something that
could be required on the back of the
extra dwellings that are now proposed
i think that responds to the points it
needs okay
thank you very much okay um gentlemen
can i come back because
well i could just give you 30 seconds
yeah that's fine it's a quick question
and the the officer said that the
infrastructure restraints was based on
an ohio figure
i can't see where that says in the ldp
so if
it was based on a higher v figure surely
that would be in the ldp because that's
evidence you have to evidence base that
statement
and b what about what about the height
rich height i maybe missed that i didn't
hear you
yeah sorry um chairman
um i uh i didn't write that one down um
in terms of the height i
i don't know how to point to a building
within the facility site that i know
is is um a similar height but if you
look at these street scenes here
and you've got street scene c and you've
got the um the flat
flatted blocks at one end and the houses
um behind them and had to go along the
eastern boundary of the site
and it the the height of those flats is
you know slightly greater than the
two-story houses but
um by a minor amount i would suggest
that the fats are still two-story um
the same as as as the houses if they
haven't got room for the roof or
anything to add
to the height and bulk of the roofs so
um
all i can say is that the application
has been assessed and
it was you know felt that these
buildings
um in the context of the site as a whole
would would not be
harmful and even if they are slightly
slightly taller than
the two-story houses and on the rest of
the site thank you
okay thank you counsellor i'll let you
have a second time again
just at the front here's shane that's it
thank you
that's that's very kind of a chair i
don't have a question actually it's uh
well i do it's a view actually all right
um so are we
are we at a stage where we're going to
vote on the recommendation or are you
um up for a proposal well uh
thank you for that then there is a there
is an officer's recommendation to
approve this uh however if there is a
proposal from the floor i'm prepared
to take that counsellor nun
yes so my proposal and we'd need mr lee
and miss matthews to help us phrase this
properly i'm sure but i would say that
we refuse this application
on the grounds of over development of
that previously approved
the loss of orchard green infrastructure
and the lack of promised bridal way
thank you
that is julie that's
very grateful to everybody i've i've got
councillor mays who has seconded that uh
i'm so i'm now going to go to the vote
members
those who are in favor of the recorded
vote
that second did okay we'll have a
recorded vote on this
this is to refuse on the grounds of over
development loss of grin
thank you it's good practice for me to
give a comment on those points
um all i would say is always um
with a recent refusal you have to be
able to demonstrate harm and the phrase
over development as
you probably noticed in the office
reports very rarely forms part of the
reason for refusal because
on its own it doesn't demonstrate harm
so you would need to
expand on what the over development
meant it could
for example if you did see it in office
report it may be that you know the
design wasn't acceptable
and the car parking requirement wasn't
met and the car parking for example was
dominant et cetera et cetera
those things result or how you can
understand what the over development is
but just use the phrase over development
on its own would be very difficult to
defend appeal because it's not clear and
precise
the loss of the orchard i think members
need
when we determine plan applications it's
not a popularity contest it's not a case
of saying
i had this application and it's better
than this application
so it wouldn't be the loss of the
orchard what it'd be is that the
proposed orchard is not considered to be
of a size or uh
an expanse that is considered to
mitigate the harm or you know the
proposed element results in an
urban development which includes you
know it's evidenced by the reduction in
the orchard etc
i know it sounds semantics but it's
quite important
in relation to actually how what reason
future should be
um formed and in relation to the loss of
a bride away
as ms matthew said i don't think there
was that i don't think everyone has ever
been granted but i think
we can we can double check that if
before a vote just look at the previous
application just
for clarity because i wouldn't want to
give any members anything
that's not accurate at least as much as
i can be thank you chairman can i
still be a question please well i just
want to go to councillor none first
because you may want to
so just on the point of clarity i didn't
just say over development i said
overdevelopment on that previously
approved
and it goes hand in hand with my second
point which is about
loss of infrastructure green
infrastructure
so my i probably have put it rather
clumsily that's why i was asking for
some
help but what i'm basically saying is by
adding the extra houses it's eating into
part of the green infrastructure so in
that respect
i feel it would be over development and
on the point of bridal way we've heard
two members here at least from their
memory
say that bride a bridal way was promised
and if a bridal way was was promised and
that was part of the reason that we
approved the process
in the first place then the bridal way
should be installed
council stamp yeah could ask mr lee um
mr lee is there a danger
that the applicant could still come back
and get rid of the rest of the orchard
for another few houses because they
changed their mind
or would we be able to put a planning
condition that would safeguard that
and trying to help counsellor nun could
it not be policy s3
place shaping is there nothing there
because i actually think it is
it is it is it's supposed to be
harmonious relationship between town and
country
and i don't see that site as being
harmonious to town and country
it is crammed now to what it originally
was going to be
to me it looks a little bit forced and
contrived would that not help at all mr
lee
thank you um to be honest sir cancer
nuns expansion on
what you just said was unacceptable good
for myself for clarity
um as i said it might seem like
semantics but as officers we can't
gift the reason for refusal but i think
yeah councillor nuns expansion was very
helpful and clarity for us to be able to
form
a you know obviously officers wouldn't
have to agree with it but
a planning based sound reason for
refusal
all right and what i'll say in relation
to broadway i just think we need to
check because obviously
we've got to be conscious that this has
got full planning permission this site
you know
and members recollection and even if
there may have been a promise that's
fallen away
if this example could be built out
tomorrow without the bride away
the current application that's why we
just need to balance that so i would
just want clarity for members before
they went to a boat on that point
thank you so much do we have have we got
white and cancer okay do we have have
you got some wording
ideas yet
briefly if you don't mind please um just
two things um one
to add to the reason for refusal we
could say that
um the combined issues of the loss of
the valuable orchard habitat
and the um increase in the
housing on that area has um
includes the uh or um
oh god i can't think of the wording i'm
tired has
caused an urbanizing effect on a rural
country area and if we can use words
that affect that covers it
and also in addition it doesn't comply
with policy s2 which is the public open
spaces because even the orchard was
formed as part of the
open public space and that's gone so i
think we do it's um
a joint thing with one being lost and
one being added to that
that's removed the benefit and the
public space
thank you council councillor channel
briefly if you don't mind
thank you chairman um this might
conflict a bit maybe the council and his
proposal
but i think the thing that bothers me a
bit is that actually the strategic
housing manager
that doesn't support the application
because the mix of the affordable
housing
i know we've heard the explanation about
the housing needs being relatively new
and it would be unreasonable but bearing
in mind the pressures we have within the
district in terms of affordable housing
and the mix
i just find it a bit strange that here
we have a proposal
when we've got a strategic housing
manager or specialist housing manager
rather
stating it might provide the 40 percent
etcetera it might have the minimum
spaces however they cannot support
because the scheme of the affordable
housing mix proposed does not comply
with the results of the 2020
lhna thank you
all right uh right counsellor none i'm
going to go
go back to you because this is your this
is your proposal
um it's his chair and it was seconded
wasn't it that was um i'd be happy to
make the amendments based
uh on the comments made by
mr lee and by councillor white and
councillor channel
so i still think that it's over
development that impacts
on loss of green infrastructure
and i'm happy to include the comments
that council
channel made and councillor white
i'm thinking about how we can word the
bridal way
if if that was not a condition
but i still think because of the rural
nature a bridal way
should be installed and there's no
indication that it would be
so if my second uh and i think that was
amazing councilor mays would be happy
with those changes
yes subject again of course to mr lee uh
we could um we could vote on that
couldn't we share right
okay i don't want to take any more
questions now i'd like to go to the vote
i think this has been well
uh yes i'll come to mr lee in a second i
think this has been well debated
i will go finally to mr to mr lee
well that's what i'm hoping mr lee will
come up with the chairman yeah
for clarity so obviously just want to
make sure everybody's aware so
the proposal would be three separate
reasons for refusal
one being the proposed development uh
the
volume i would suggest that members are
stating on the level of development
has resulted in a form of element that
does not reflect the rule or character
the area
and that you know that would appear to
be my understanding of what the debate
has been and what councillor
nuns highlighted issues weren't
obviously
you know as always we'll form it up
properly through the
and uh obviously recommend we delegate
that to officers and through agreement
of the
chair um the second one would be to the
fact that the proposal does not include
the vision of her
right away and then the third reason
would be in relation to the
housing mix not reflecting the local
housing needs assessment
is not that correct
yeah that would be included in the uh
the original one that relates to the
urban nature it doesn't reflect before i
go to the thank you for that before i go
is there anything you want to add to
that council schemes i i i
just remind everybody this is a
beautiful corner of burnham
lovely ancient church one of the most
beautiful churches in the area
uh and i don't feel this is fitting
especially with these editions
okay all right thank you very much i'm
going to go to the vote now members by
this is for councillor nuns um
proposal to refuse that it's been duly
seconded
by councillor mays could i i've been
asked for a recorded vote
so miss bird could i ask you to call the
role please
thank you chairman members um if you
could indicate before against rob stein
when i call your name please
starting with councillor miss beale
this is to this is to refuse the
application
to refuse it
for your for the actual refusal so your
four councillors
council
[Music]
houvener councillor hull
councillor lagan councillor mays
for councillor nunn
councillor shawnee councillor
councillor schemes four councillor stamp
for councillor stevens
councillors stilts that's the swain
or council mrs thompson
councillor miss white chairman the
results of that vote are 1841 against
and love sanctions thank you
that is therefore carried then um thank
you very much
members um agenda item six
is any other items of the business that
that the chairman of the committee
decides
are urgent i have none uh therefore
officers and members i thank you for
your contributions this evening
and i'm going to draw this meeting to a
close at 20
45 as it's now closed members are
advised not to enter into any
further
you